deep in the Hundred Acre Woods a young
boy named Christopher Robin came across
some most unusual adolescent creatures
crossbreeds
who some would describe as abomination
the creatures introduced themselves as
Owen rabbit Eeyore Piglet and most
importantly
Winnie the Pooh
with the naivety of Youth Christopher
ignored the dangers and befriended them
all
he brought them food and with each
passing day together their bond
strengthened and grew
the days turned to years and with the
years came maturity
eventually Christopher had to make the
hard decision to leave his friends to
attend college to become a doctor
requiring them to fend for themselves
once more
then winter arrived
the nights were deathly cold with the
land Barren and completely devoid of
food
one fateful night
and on the brink of starvation
who decided that in order to survive the
group must consume one of their dearest
friends
and thus
Eeyore was no more
[Music]
and the trauma of this act walked the
minds of the group
they became feral and developed a hatred
to All Things human
and in particular
Christopher Robin for abandoning them
a pact was made
they renounced their humanity and
returned to their animalistic Roots
swearing never to talk again